[APPLAUSE]
FEMALE SPEAKER 1: Joey
Del Marco was raped.
Or so she says.
A couple weeks ago she pre-gamed
with some of the junior guys
from our school-- Tim
Delaney, Luke Friedman,
and George Wright.
They finished a bottle
of vodka and crammed
into the backseat
of a cab and that's
when she said it happened.
She's saying that's
when they raped her.
But the guys are just
saying that she was wasted
and just hooked up
with all of them.
But the thing is, if
you know Joey at all,
her story is pretty fucking hard
to believe because Joey is all
like, yeah, I'm a slut.
And I own my sexuality.
And I'm on the dance team.
And I hook up.
And look where it got her.
It landed her in the
backseat of a cab
with a group of boys who
think that she wants it
because she pretty much
acts like she wants it.
You know what I'm saying?
And the boys, Tim, Luke,
and George, were arrested.
And now they're on
academic probation waiting
for all of this to play out.
And no one's heard from Joey.
None of her friends
on the dance team
and especially not
her best friend Anna.
Anna's actually Tim's sister
and Tim was one of the guys
there that night.
My friend James' mom told
my mom that she heard
Joey was talking to lawyers.
What do I think?
Honestly, I don't
know what to think.
So.
FEMALE SPEAKER 2: So I
remember that the driver was
black but not African American.
He was, like,
actually from Africa.
I'm sorry-- I-- I'm
sorry, I just-- I
don't really
remember specifically
what he looked like.
If I saw him again I
might recognize him.
Is there any way we could
track him down or something?
I mean, don't they
have to submit a log
or submit the
starting and ending
point of the trip or whatever?
Because I just-- I don't
really remember specifically
what he looked like.
OK.
Um, he had really, really
dark skin and no facial hair
and a shaved head and he might
have been in his 40s, maybe.
And I remember he was playing
music really, really loud.
And Tim asked him to
turn it down a little.
But the guy just
completely ignored him.
FEMALE SPEAKER 3: What's up?
OK, well, it's off now.
FEMALE SPEAKER 2: So it was
Tim, Luke, me, and then George.
And sort of in order for us
to all fit in comfortably--
FEMALE SPEAKER 3: What?
FEMALE SPEAKER 2: I sort of
slung my leg over George's.
FEMALE SPEAKER 3: Nothing?
FEMALE SPEAKER 2:
But it was nothing.
I mean, my dress was
still completely covered.
FEMALE SPEAKER 3:
Just, you know, like,
looking Facebook and stuff?
OK, can you shut the door?
What?
FEMALE SPEAKER 2:
What were we doing?
FEMALE SPEAKER 3: Why?
What's she doing?
FEMALE SPEAKER 2: Uh,
just hanging out, and--
FEMALE SPEAKER 3: I mean,
is she yelling at dad,
or is she just crying again?
FEMALE SPEAKER 2: It wasn't--
FEMALE SPEAKER 3: What
do you want her to do?
This is just, like--
FEMALE SPEAKER 2:
--bad right away.
FEMALE SPEAKER 3: --bad, Tim.
She loves you so it's just bad.
How am I looking at you?
No I'm not.
No I haven't.
I haven't at all, Tim.
It's just, like, the past
three weeks all I've done
is go to school, pick
up Thea, and come home.
And you guys are, like, huddled
in the kitchen or somewhere
and I'm not a part of any of it.
OK, well, then come
in and shut the door.
No, it's just that,
Tim, you're my brother.
And I'm really
worried about you.
FEMALE SPEAKER 2: I just--
I don't know exactly how
I should say everything.
You know, I think about it
all the time, constantly.
I just-- saying it
out loud is just--
FEMALE SPEAKER 3: Did you do it?
Yes, yes, no, I
know you said, no!
No, of course I believe you,
but if you didn't doing anything
then why were you
fucking arrested?
And, like, now you're
on academic probation?
FEMALE SPEAKER 2: I should
say all the details, or--
FEMALE SPEAKER 3:
So tell me, then.
Just tell me.
Because Mom and Dad know all
the details and the lawyers
do, but I don't know anything.
And I'm at school all
day, you know, like,
hearing all of this
stuff, and we haven't even
talked about it.
OK.
So tell me then.
FEMALE SPEAKER 2: So we were
sort of dancing in the back,
and George was keeping
the beat on my leg.
And I know that sounds weird.
He was sort of, like,
playing the drums on my leg.
FEMALE SPEAKER 3: You know how
Joey gets when she's drunk.
FEMALE SPEAKER 2:
And then George and I
started to sort of
make out for a second,
but that was only
for, like, a second.
And then he kind of started
to put his hand up my leg.
FEMALE SPEAKER 3:
I also know how
you guys get when you're drunk.
FEMALE SPEAKER 2: But, you
know, I slapped it away,
like in a friendly way.
Except he did it again.
Except this time his hand
sort of went up my skirt
and, like, grazed
my crotch a little.
And I started to
get sort of nervous.
And I clamped down on
his hand with my hands.
And I looked at him, and
he was looking past at Luke
with this face on.
And I don't really know how
to describe the face exactly,
but it was sort of like, hey
dude, look what I'm doing.
And I looked at him.
And I said, George,
come on, stop.
Just wait until we
get to Connor's.
I mean, I'm not sure
I said "stop" exactly,
but it was very clear
that I wanted him to stop.
I mean, I was trying to
pull my leg off of his
and push his hand off
of me, but I mean,
he was grabbing my skin.
He was, like, clawing it.
I don't know.
I don't know if I would've done
anything with him at Connor's.
I was just saying that.
No, I was just saying
that so he would stop
doing that stuff in the cab.
It seemed like a pretty
good idea at the time.
FEMALE SPEAKER 3: Nothing.
Sorry, no.
Nothing.
I'm just picturing
her, you know?
OK.
So what happened next?
FEMALE SPEAKER 2:
So the next thing
I know, Luke is grabbing
my other leg and sort
of pulling it to the side.
So my legs would be
more, like, open.
And then George kind of
put his leg over mine
to kind of hold it down,
and then they both just
started pushing their
shoulders into my shoulders
against the back of the seat--
like, sort of like that.
And I started to
cry at that point.
And I mean, I could barely move.
And they were pinning me down.
And then George just started
to pull my dress up and just
pull it up farther.
Sorry, how much
detail do you need?
FEMALE SPEAKER 3: I hate
thinking of her struggling,
because you know,
George and Luke
are so much bigger than her.
You know, I would've
been beside myself
hysterical if I was being
pinned down by the two of them.
I would have been screaming
like a psycho or something.
I don't get them.
FEMALE SPEAKER 2:
And then George
just, really aggressively, like,
pulled my underwear to the side
and jammed his
two fingers in me.
FEMALE SPEAKER 3:
That's disgusting.
So what did you do?
What did you do when they
started doing that to her?
FEMALE SPEAKER 2: I mean,
I was crying at that point.
I was hysterically crying,
but I couldn't scream.
I could not make a
scream come out of me.
It felt like I was choking.
FEMALE SPEAKER 3: And the cab
driver didn't notice anything?
FEMALE SPEAKER 2:
I mean, there's
a good chance he
didn't hear anything.
You know, I remember the
music was, like, really loud.
I said that.
But I remember I was staring so
hard into the rear view mirror,
kind of just wondering
if he would catch my eye.
But I was horrified
at the thought.
I mean, I was so embarrassed.
And my vagina was
completely exposed.
And I kept thinking, if this
guy turns around and sees me
like this, we're going
to get in a car accident.
FEMALE SPEAKER 3: Well, why
didn't you stop the cab?
FEMALE SPEAKER 2: George
had his fingers in me.
Two.
Yeah, I'm sure.
Because I saw them.
Uh, he was sort of
moving them in and out,
I guess, like, in
a stabbing motion.
And I mean, he was really
putting his whole body into it
and I was sort of
squeezing everything,
trying to close myself
up, which probably
made it hurt a lot more.
And the whole time Luke
is making fun of George
because I'm not
cumming-- because I'm not
having an orgasm.
And he was like,
dude, do you even
know what the fuck you're doing?
You make girls cry you're
so bad at that shit.
You're giving this poor
girl fucking pussy burn.
And George was like,
fuck you, dude.
It's not me.
Her pussy's as dry
as a fucking desert.
Uh-- and then Luke
sort of laughed,
and then he put his
fingers in his mouth.
And I started to
freak out because I
knew what he was going to do.
And I started to
really go crazy.
And then that's when
George said, I quote,
I feel like we're
fucking wrestling
an alligator or some shit.
FEMALE SPEAKER 3: Did
he seriously say that?
FEMALE SPEAKER 2:
I need a second.
I-- yeah.
So George said the alligator
thing and Luke laughed.
And then he just did the
same thing as George,
except he was trying
to, like, show off.
And he was like, come on, Joey.
I know you want to cum.
I know you're wet now.
And then he seemed to get sort
of tired or annoyed with me.
And he was like, wow, I guess
you're all talk, huh, Joey?
And then they let go of me.
FEMALE SPEAKER 3: I hate them.
FEMALE SPEAKER 2: I hate them
whenever I think about it.
FEMALE SPEAKER 3: You know,
that is most disgusting thing
I've ever heard.
And I don't understand.
She said, no, right?
FEMALE SPEAKER 2: Yeah, I said
no through the whole thing.
I was like, come on, no.
Don't.
Stop.
I don't want to do this.
FEMALE SPEAKER 3: So
what were you doing?
FEMALE SPEAKER 2: Tim was
just looking out the window.
FEMALE SPEAKER 3: Well,
why didn't you do anything?
You sat there, Tim.
You didn't text anybody?
You didn't stop the cab.
You didn't even say
anything to them.
I'm like, what the hell
are you guys doing?
Stop.
But you were a part of it.
You were there while your two
best friends were doing crazy
shit to a girl you've
known your whole life,
and she clearly wasn't into it.
FEMALE SPEAKER 2:
I really don't want
him to get in a lot of
trouble for all this
because he's actually
a really good guy.
And he works really hard.
And honestly, he probably
just didn't know what to do.
And that's not
totally his fault.
And mainly he's-- he's the
twin brother of one of my best
friends, Anna.
I haven't really talked
to her since then.
FEMALE SPEAKER 3: I mean,
you looked at your phone
and you stared out
the fucking window.
Why?
Maybe you were drunker
than you thought.
FEMALE SPEAKER 2: Sorry, I
actually don't feel very well.
FEMALE SPEAKER 3: Because
you know her, Tim.
She's one of my best friends.
She's gone, like,
camping with us.
FEMALE SPEAKER 2: How much
longer is this going to be?
FEMALE SPEAKER 3: You're
right, I really don't get it.
Were you afraid they were
going to hurt you or something?
Because you know, like,
I know what they're
like when they're drunk.
OK, so do you remember
that time when
we were in Brooklyn and Luke
took that rock from in front
of the church on Clinton
Street and just smashed it
into the window of the car?
You know, he was out of control.
Do you think he was going to
do something like that to you?
FEMALE SPEAKER 2: No, no.
I'm fine to keep going, I just--
FEMALE SPEAKER 3: OK.
So then tell me, because
you're my brother
and I know you better
than anybody, right?
And I just keep thinking
about Thea, Tim.
And how we would literally
kill anybody who did
anything close to that to her.
I mean, just picture her-- you
know, not knowing what to do,
and then feeling so
scared and so trapped.
And that's how Joey felt.
And you didn't do
anything to help her
so that's why this thing is,
like, a fucking nightmare to me
or something.
Because you're not that guy.
FEMALE SPEAKER 2: The last
thing I remember seeing
was Columbus Circle Mall.
FEMALE SPEAKER 3: I
know it happened fast.
FEMALE SPEAKER 2: And then we
were at 78th and Lexington.
FEMALE SPEAKER 3: No, I won't.
Please tell me.
FEMALE SPEAKER 2:
I didn't get out.
I should have.
I just-- I didn't
know what to do.
I-- my underwear was
ripped and I was sore
and I just stared
at the taxi TV.
They were trying to talk to me.
They were sort of teasing me.
And Luke, like, put
his arm around me
and said something like,
come on, Joey, give me a hug.
You're like the
most down girl ever.
And Tim was just
staring out the window.
FEMALE SPEAKER 3: He
didn't want to be a pussy.
FEMALE SPEAKER 2: The cab pulled
up at Conner's at I threw $10.
FEMALE SPEAKER 3:
That's totally fucked.
And I believe you, Tim,
and I love you a lot, OK?
But you have to know
that's totally fucked.
Guys don't do that
to other guys.
FEMALE SPEAKER 2: Yeah.
I locked myself in the
bathroom when we got up there,
and I puked everywhere.
FEMALE SPEAKER 3:
Because so what
if they called you a pussy?
Like, what would've happened?
Would you have lost
them as friends?
Would you have died?
OK.
So then don't be a pussy, Tim.
FEMALE SPEAKER 2:
Jane helped me.
She gave me her underwear and
we called my parents and I got
home around 10:30-ish.
FEMALE SPEAKER 3: Why
would the lawyer say that?
FEMALE SPEAKER 2:
I told my parents.
They were really good about it.
My mom put my underwear
in a Ziploc bag
because I guess she thought
there was evidence on them.
And my dad cried, which
really made me cry.
FEMALE SPEAKER 3: But
that stuff doesn't matter
because you know they did it.
FEMALE SPEAKER 2: They're
just disappointed.
FEMALE SPEAKER 3: Yes, Tim.
More than anything, I
obviously want what's
going to be best for you.
I just don't understand
how that's right, though.
Yeah, mom?
Yeah, he's right here.
OK, yeah.
We're coming.
I hate our family like this.
Go.
Yeah.
Yeah, I'm coming.
I'm just realizing, I'm
probably never going
to talk to Joey again, right?
FEMALE SPEAKER 2:
10 to 15 minutes.
Everything happened in only,
like, 10 to 15 minutes.
That's how long it took for
my life to just implode.
And now I'm slutty girl who
shouldn't have been there
and I shouldn't
have gotten drunk
have done everything
that everybody's saying
that I shouldn't have done.
But how is it about everything
that I shouldn't have done?
And now I'm that girl.
And I don't want to be.
FRED: Hi, everyone.
I'm going to read something
that I wrote for this book.
I wrote it last year
about something that
happened to me in sixth grade.
You watch porn?
Lenny asks me with one
of his very signature
smiles-- the kind of smile
that almost makes you feel bad.
I don't really want to
answer Lenny's question.
Talking about porn
makes me uncomfortable.
I start to feel tense.
Plus, there's a bunch of
other guys in the room.
It's sixth grade, and I
just started hanging out
with this new group of kids.
We're at Julian's
house, and I'm sitting
on the couch with Julian,
Jake, Stephen, and Aaron.
Lenny is sitting on a chair
staring at me with his smile,
waiting for an answer.
He probably knows I don't
really want to talk about it,
but that doesn't
matter much to him.
He wants his answer,
so he repeats himself.
Do you watch porn?
I started watching porn
mid-year fifth grade.
I'd just begun middle
school and befriended
a lot of kids in seventh
and eighth grade,
and sometimes when I
hung out with them,
they'd make jokes about
the porn they watch,
referencing certain sites.
After a little bit, I decided
to Google some of these sites
and was pretty shocked.
Obviously, I wasn't shocked
because the videos contain
breasts, vaginas, and penises.
I expected that.
I was shocked because
these videos seemed
to take place in their very
own world with their own rules
and mentality.
I had entered a world,
where instead of referring
to the woman by name,
they're referred
to by this combination of
their hair color, skin color,
and the added word
slut or whore.
I'd entered a world where
every girl is recorded saying
she wants it and craves cum.
It was a world where after
each girl was fucked,
she would blow a
kiss to the camera
and the screen would fade to
black, happily ever after.
This seemingly
simplistic, dehumanization
of sex that would always
end with the girl being
told how dirty she was and
never anybody else involved.
It was a strange world.
And even then, I knew I
wasn't really on board
with most of it.
But I still continued to watch.
And lots of days, after
coming home from school
I'd watch porn.
It was like marathoning
this awful TV show
where you feel a
strange addictiveness
while watching and then
like crap when you finish.
I thought it'd be easier
to not actually think
about what I was watching
when I watched it and decided
I'd separate my normal self
from my porn-watching self
completely.
I was very secretive
about it, telling nobody.
This was the opposite for
guys like Lenny and Julian.
So many days after school,
I sat and listened to them
describe the porn they
watched or even sometimes
what other guys watched.
I remember Julian saying to
me, yo, Lenny likes big girls,
he was watching video of
these fat hos, and then laugh.
And so Lenny repeats
his question.
He's still looking at me, and
he's getting kind of angry
that I haven't answered him yet.
I kind of mumble, yeah,
I've watched it a few times.
He laughs the kind of laugh
that you know is at you.
It's the answer he wanted.
Around four months later,
I'm in the schoolyard talking
to Julian, and Julian
says how he really
doesn't like Lenny anymore.
He lists a couple of incidents
where Lenny came to his house
and wrecked his things.
Also, the thing with
Jessica, Julian says.
What thing, I ask him.
He said, two months
ago, he, Stephen,
and Lenny went to
Jessica's house,
a girl who goes to our school.
Lenny started getting
wild, and he put his penis
on Jessica's leg.
She was sitting
in her own house,
just hanging out
with a bunch of kids
who she thought were
her good friends.
And Lenny took his penis
and he slapped it on her
because he felt like it,
while Stephen and Julian stood
and watched.
As shocking as everything
was, the reactions
were maybe the most shocking.
I overheard kids saying
how Jessica had made it up.
And some girls in
our school said
she must wanted it to happen.
A group of eighth
graders were high-fiving
Lenny in the hallway,
laughing and smiling.
I still remember one of them
nodding at Lenny, saying, nice.
What's scary is, as much as one
can wish to separate themselves
from what they watch or attempt
to not analyze or question
anything that happens
in those videos,
it's impossible because it
overlaps into our culture.
The world of porn bleeds
its way into reality.
The "she wanted it"
mentality of porn
makes its way into the
opinions of 13-year-olds,
even when it's so obvious that
she definitely did not want it.
And objectification
of women does not
stay within the
confines of a video.
It does not fade away
like a video's final shot.
Permanent harm is done.
Because the most accessible way
that guys of all ages view sex
should not encourage
a male-female dynamic
that's degrading and unreal.
But that's the main
thing that's out there
at the click of your mouse.
And it's scary and
it's unfortunate
and it's unfair for
everybody involved.
And it's even more frightening
how these cycles continue,
how guys like Lenny keep on
coming, because guys like Lenny
keep on understanding
sex as something
that they can win or
take because that's how
it's being presented to them.
Lenny learns to not be
empathetic around sex.
It can be something
he's entitled to
and something where the sole
purpose is to please himself
in whatever way he wants.
And so many of us are so
uncomfortable with sex or rape
that we blind ourselves
to what's going on,
and we let it continue.
It's been over two years
since everything happened.
I'm in eighth grade
now, and I didn't
realize how everything connected
until I first saw "Slut."
I didn't even realize how
much Jessica must have had
to go through the whole time.
She felt ashamed
for being a victim
and walked through the
hallways of my school
as if nothing had happened.
I also don't hang out with
Julian and all those guys
anymore.
Recently, in school, though,
we had Family Living class,
and I had to sit
right next to Lenny.
As a class, we started
addressing scary incidents,
and one girl shared
about a time when
she was harassed by a
stranger on the street who
told her she had a cute butt.
Lenny couldn't stop giggling.
I turned to look at him, and
I saw on Lenny's face one
of his very signature smiles.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
ODLEY: Hello, everyone.
My name is Odley.
I'm just going to read a
testimony I wrote over a year
ago about how I've witnessed
the media portraying women.
"When I was a
little kid starting
at about seven years old,
I loved to listen to music
and watch music videos.
I loved hip-hop, R&B,
a little bit of rap,
pop, rock--
basically everything.
As long as it was
catchy, I loved it.
I would sing along
to these songs,
having no clue what the artists
were singing and rapping about.
I would watch the
music videos and see
nothing but African
American women
in bikinis having a good
time and getting attention
from lots of guys.
One of the songs I
really enjoyed was,
"Big Pimpin'" by Jay Z. Damn,
that cruise ship looked fun.
[LAUGHTER]
Al the beautiful women,
their amazing swim suits,
smiling, dancing around
the men while champagne
was being poured on
their faces-- I mean,
it seemed like a great
time to me at the time.
I was a young girl, just
dancing to the beat,
drooling over the
glamorous lifestyle
and laughing, completely unaware
of what was really being said.
As I got older I started
to listen to the lyrics,
and I begun to understand
what was being said.
Just recently, I was watching
"Throwback Jams" on MTV,
and I heard a familiar beat.
I looked up at the TV, and it
was "Big Pimpin'," big and bold
on my TV.
I got up, started dancing
and rapping with H.O.V.A.
'You know I fuck 'em,
love 'em, leave 'em.
I love this song so much.
Yeah, I got up and starting
rapping with H.O.V.A.,
you know I, thug 'em, fuck
'em, love 'em, leave 'em,
'cause I don't fucking need 'em.
Take 'em out the hood,
keep 'em looking good,
but I don't fucking feed 'em.
First time they fuss I'm
breezing, talkin' about, what's
the reason.
I pimp in the every sense of
the word, bitch, better trust
and believe 'em.
I was suddenly like, OK, whoa.
That's kind of messed up,
but kept jamming to the song.
Then I heard, hard
cold-ass assassin.
I got no passion.
I got no patience,
and I hate waiting.
Ho get your ass in the car
and less ride-i-i-i-i-i-ide.
You know, everybody
know that part.
I stopped and thought, ho?
I looked up at the
TV to make sure
these women in the video
reacted to what was just said,
but no, they just kept dancing.
I sat back down and wondered,
did anyone hear this but me?
And the song continued to play.
It wasn't until
the end of the song
that I realized this
whole entire thing was
about spending money,
playing women, and abusing
women and treating them
less as human beings.
Pimping women, basically.
The lucky women in these videos
are just things, toys, scenery,
not people.
They're self-worth is
completely diminished.
Yeah, it's OK to be
sexy, but in these videos
the women have no control.
Girls are taught to want
to be like these women,
because, come on,
who wouldn't want
to be partying with Jay-Z
on his bad-ass yacht, right?
And what guy doesn't want to
be Jigga with a rap career
and cash and bottles
of Cristal and a boat
full of half-naked sluts, right?
There is a very unhealthy
male to female dynamic being
modeled in these videos
by celebrities we worship.
In the media, African
American women
are often portrayed as
voluptuous and sexual
with ratchet ghetto attitudes
and three baby daddies.
And music videos pack
the biggest punch
against these women of color.
Instead of rapping about
our beauty and our strength,
male recording
artists are calling us
sexy bitches and fine-ass hos.
Instead of showing
us affection, they're
pouring alcoholic beverages on
our faces, throwing cash at us,
telling us to play with
a dick in the truck.
As an African
American woman, I have
to stand up and
fight against this.
I should not have
to feel like I have
to mimic the women
of these videos
to get attention
from boys I like.
And boys should not expect us
to be and act the same way.
Maybe if the media
didn't portray us
as hos, bitch, big
booty Judys, or sluts,
we would get a
little more respect
and have a little more
room to just be who we are.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
EMILY MORTIMER: I
am Emily Mortimer,
and I'm an actor and a
writer and am various things.
But I'm also a mother.
And as a parent of a
five-year-old daughter--
and perhaps more importantly,
an 11-year-old son-- I
was just incredibly
drawn to Katie
and Meg's amazing project.
These two are the forces behind
this whole thing and the two
ladies who have teased
this incredible stuff out
of their students and got
this project off the ground.
And it's become this thing, this
little engine that could now.
And they've taken it
all over the country
and have used it as a tool
for education everywhere.
Anyway-- but I wanted to find
out more when I heard about it.
And I wanted to be more educated
about teenage gender politics
and sexuality and
what really goes on
between young men
and young women.
But as I talked to Katie
and read more of this book,
I realized that it's
not just my children who
can benefit from an open
discussion about these things.
I can too.
And I'm 43.
And you know, I
do feel-- and I've
felt it more and more as
I've heard these stories
and read the book and
talked to these guys--
that as an educated,
liberated woman in 2015
with a career and an
independent income,
it turns out that I'm still just
as confused about these issues
as I was when I was 14 and 15,
and that I'm still struggling
with how to square
the need to be
a strong and driven woman with
a desire and need to be desired
and to desire.
And how to keep a
sense of who I am
and what it is that I really
want through all of this.
Sex is confusing for everyone,
not just for teenagers.
And I think the more
we're all encouraged
to talk about what confuses
us, the better we'll
understand each
other and the better
we'll understand ourselves.
In the afterword to the
book, Carol Gilligan
talks about wanting
the discussion
about sex and morality to
be about what women really
think as opposed to what
we think we should think.
And I love that Katie and
Meg and all these brilliant,
brave, honest, talented
young people who
have put on this play
and shared their stories
and helped to write this
book have encouraged us
and continue to encourage us to
understand what we really think
and to say it.
So thank you so much, guys.
And I think they are going to
answer some questions that I'm
going to start off by asking.
And then if you
guys have anything
that you'd like
to ask them, then
start brainstorming now
as to what they might be.
But first of all, Katie and
Meg-- so "Slut" started off
as a play and then evolved
into this whole sort
of student activist movement.
And now it's this book.
Can you tell us a little
bit about the journey
and the story of "Slut"?
KATIE CAPPIELLO: Yeah.
So Meg and I founded
an arts and activism
project called the Arts
Effect eight years ago.
And the goal of that project is
to bring young people together
to create plays based
on the challenges
that they face in their lives.
A dynamic component of our
project is an all-girl theatre
company.
The girls are 11
to 20 years old,
and "Slut" came
out of their lives.
We were sitting around
talking, like we always do.
And the word slut, the
idea of slut shaming,
sexuality, sexual
aggression, rape,
was popping up in every single
conversation we had with them.
And we'd meet with them
once a week for three hours.
And it was all we
could talk about.
So we knew it was something
that we needed to dive into.
So we spent a year and a half
improving, creative writing,
reflective writing, having
more and more discussion.
Sometimes we'd just
sit there and talk
for three hours about
every possible way
we could tackle this issue.
And then we had a script.
MEGAN MCINERNEY: Yeah.
And the first time we
actually performed the play
was part of an international
theater festival
here in New York City.
And after the performances,
we were so struck by the fact
that the audiences would
just stand in the street.
It was hundreds
of people standing
in the street of New York City.
And they wouldn't want
to leave, because they
wanted to keep talking.
And so we realized that
there was quite a need
to have this conversation
and that people wanted it.
So we created, then, the Stop
Slut coalition, the Stop Slut
movement, to help
fulfill this need.
And we now have hundreds of
chapters, thousands of members
all throughout the country.
We have 20 chapters here
alone in New York City
that are comprised of
students, young people.
Our youngest is 11
to 20 years old.
And they're the experts.
So they're the ones that
understand the nuances of how
this culture is affecting them.
And they are creating their
own individual plans of action
for how they can combat
slut shaming and rape
culture in their communities.
KATIE CAPPIELLO: Yeah.
So when the Feminist Press
came to us about a year ago
and said, would you be
interested in putting
a book together,
and the book would
contain the script and
essays by young people,
also essays by leading
activists and writers,
and then an activism guide,
we jumped on the chance.
Because our goal has
always been to provide
young people-- and
also their educators,
their parents, those in
their lives-- with tools
to safely unpack issues and
effectively take action.
And for us, theater
and storytelling
has always been the way in.
So that's where we are.
MEGAN MCINERNEY:
That's what we did.
EMILY MORTIMER:
Winnifred, you've
been part of this project
since the very beginning.
And I wondered if
you could help us
to understand what slut shaming
is and how it can lead to rape.
WINNIFRED BONJEAN-ALPART: Yeah.
Slut shaming is a way to
target female sexuality,
to demean and degrade
a women's self-worth.
And in terms of the
perpetuation of rape culture,
I think, because it sort
of hijacks a woman's right
to own her sexuality
and display it
in whatever way she wants
or feels comfortable with,
we then take away her power.
And then we as a culture
have consistently used it
and used the word slut to
delegitimize the experiences
of victims and survivors.
So yeah, when you take away
a woman's standing and power
in terms of her
sexuality, she is then
vulnerable to be a victim.
EMILY MORTIMER: And as
young girls in 2015,
how do you sort of reconcile
the confusing issues
of how to be a sort of
sexual, fully realized
being in the world,
as well as how
to keep hold of your power--
and especially when there's
so much in our
culture that it is
telling you to flaunt
yourselves and that there
is power in that?
I mean, I find it confusing.
I find Miley Cyrus
really confusing.
Because on the
one hand, I think,
that's fantastic that this
girl is feeling free enough
to be that way
and sort of owning
her sexuality in that way.
But on the other hand,
it's confusing, you know?
And I wonder how you
guys live with that
as young women in the world
and how you kind of deal
with that in your own brains.
WINNIFRED BONJEAN-ALPART: Yeah.
I think, like you said, it's
really, really challenging
to answer that.
I think walking the line is
probably one of my greatest
challenges in the last
couple of years because yeah,
as you said, you
want to be sexual.
That's natural.
And you have these
conflicting messages.
We hear about them all the
time, where on one side,
everyone's telling you, yeah,
no, everyone wants this.
We want you to act this way.
We want you to reveal yourself.
Do it.
And then you're
getting shamed for it.
So I think I've personally
found it nearly impossible
to negotiate that.
But I think part of it is
taking away the stigma instead
of saying, proudly
reclaiming, yeah, you
know what, I am a
slut, I have a right
to own my sexuality
as a woman and I
should be able to do
that without having
to claim this word, which
is essentially degrading.
So I feel like being able
to confidently discuss
these issues has enabled me
with tools to sort of have more
of an internal understanding.
So I can't really change
what other people are
doing or saying about me, but
if I have a sense of self,
and I do-- a lot of it is
because of this group-- then
I am able to combat it.
EMILY MORTIMER: Yeah.
And that's awesome.
And what I feel like
from hearing you all
and reading the book
is that, in a way,
what you're owning is
the complexity of it
and the confusion of
it and that that's
so much of an important
part of the discussion.
It's not like everything
is going to be made clear.
It's just that you're
owning that this
is difficult
territory, and it needs
to be talked about in as
honestly a way as possible.
OK, cool.
Now, Eliza and
Darci, you've both
traveled with the play
across the country.
And I just wondered how people
have responded, how audiences
have responded in the different
places that you've been to,
to the play.
ELIZA PRICE: Yeah, so I
remember the first time
we put this on, in August 2013.
I had a friend come to see it.
And she called
other girls sluts.
And you know, when guys
would call her sloppy,
she would just giggle
and laugh it off.
And I remember she
saw this play and it
changed her whole
outlook on everything
because now she's one of the
biggest feminists I know.
And it changes her
outlook, and it
makes her think twice
about what guys say to her
and how she should respond.
And my mom's friends also
remember their childhood
and teenage-hood.
I have a 14-year-old brother.
And I think watching his
reaction was the most powerful
to me because he
called girls sluts
and he talked about
the word pimp a lot.
And then he saw
this, and it really
changed his view of
the world because he
was able to really think
about it and go into school
and talk to his friends and
stand up for this cause.
And I think that was so powerful
because he was young and a boy,
and you don't see that as often.
And that's how it's happened
everywhere we've been.
DARCI SIEGEL: Yeah.
Like Eliza said, seeing all of
the reactions after the shows
have been so powerful.
Almost a year ago we went
to Fargo, North Dakota,
to do a couple of shows.
And we also had a Stop
Slut meeting at one
of the local high schools.
And something that
I will never forget
is after one of the shows
we have a talk back where
the cast will come on stage
and we have the ability
to have an open conversation
with the audience.
And we had this one
girl who was 16 or 17.
And she stood up in
front of everyone.
And she was crying,
and she was shaking.
And she told us that she
came to the realization
after seeing the show that
an experience that she
had had a couple
months before was rape.
And she didn't fully comprehend
the magnitude of the issue
until seeing "Slut."
And when she came
forward and she
talked about her truth
and her experience,
a handful of other women also
came forward from the audience
and told their stories.
And what was really
incredible is
that we had a lot of high
school students in the audience
also that night.
And the next day we went
to their high school,
and they all came.
And we sat down for
three or four hours
and just had a
conversation with them.
And they were very
strong because they
saw how this had
affected their peers,
and they wanted
to make a change.
So we sat and we
had a conversation.
And they came up with the
plan that-- they were having
their prom the next weekend.
And they decided that when the
song "Blurred Lines" came on,
they were all going to
try and get as many people
as they could to walk
off the dance floor.
And we were flying
back to New York.
And I remember, I
got off the plane,
and I turned my phone on.
And I got a text from one
of the girls from Fargo.
And she texted me,
oh my gosh, Darci,
you'll never guess
what happened.
So we had our prom,
and half of our grade
walked off the dance floor
when "Blurred Lines" came on.
And it made me so proud seeing
the impact that "Slut" has.
Because when you provide
people with the space
and with the platform to
have these conversations,
they're ready to have
the conversations
and they're ready
to take action.
EMILY MORTIMER: And I love
how a lot of the conversations
seem to be between
boys and girls
and that boys seemed to be
very interested in having
the conversation too
because they're just
as confused as the girls are.
And Fred is our
brave boy here who
shared his story so
eloquently and so brilliantly.
And I'd love to
know what you think
about the importance
of guys being part
of this movement and all that.
FRED: Yeah.
So obviously everybody
is involved with it,
meaning that for the
movement to work everyone
should be involved in it.
So it's like, there's
pressures on both ends,
and there's limitations
on both ends.
If I go to a party,
I don't want to feel
like I have to make the
first move every time.
Or like, if I'm walking
with a friend of mine
and then someone walks by, I
don't feel like I have to say,
to prove to him, oh,
she's hot or something.
The way that its works is
that-- because we're all
talking about conversation,
and that's what's
important, at least
in this point.
The first thing is
just to talk, to be
able-- not to even say,
oh, it should be this
or it should be
that, but to just
say, my personal reaction to
this is this, And you know,
a real experience.
And so many people-- it's built
in this hesitation to do that.
And it's built in this
way to kind of not
have to-- you don't
want to talk about it.
And it's really hard to make
that jump to consciousness,
to be like, hey, let's
have this conversation.
I don't know.
I was, like, really
nervous to even do
this, because it's Google and
it's on YouTube or whatever.
But still, the reason
that I wrote that
was because I saw the play.
And it's this thing
where, like, we
shouldn't be telling
people what to think.
We should just say,
this is my experience.
And once you do, that's
empowering to other people
to then be able to talk about.
So I think it really
involves everybody, yeah.
EMILY MORTIMER: Awesome.
Have you guys got questions?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
EMILY MORTIMER: That's
why you're standing there?
Yeah.
So ask away.
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
This is how we
usually do it, but I
don't think we ever said that.
But thank you guys so
much for being here.
It was a really
powerful performance,
and the readings were great.
Kind of on that last point,
I struggle with this issue
because I feel like people who
elect to come to these events
are people who already get it.
How do you get people who
don't get it yet to come?
And Eliza, I loved your
story about your brother.
That's so powerful.
And Fred, was it?
I loved that you're here too.
And how do we get
more allies in?
KATIE CAPPIELLO: You
know, it's interesting
because we have the
same conversation.
And it is definitely
one of the reasons
why we titled our play "Slut."
Lots of high school kids want
to see a play called "Slut."
It's not like, Joey's bad
night where things went wrong.
You know, not to
lighten it, but when
we had early conversations about
how we should title this play,
we were like, let's
pack a punch here.
Let's get the kids in.
We also find the key
is just inviting them.
Seriously, Fred's the
lone guy here today--
obviously meaning on this stage.
But there are so many boys
that are in this audience.
The audience without fail
is always 50-50 male-female.
Boys come out to this play.
They want to talk
about this play.
about the issues.
And we found it's just
a matter of sending them
a text and Facebook
inviting them.
You know, the girls
get on their phones
and they get on Snapchat,
and they're just
inviting everybody.
And they actually
show up because it's
the thing to do Saturday night.
No, it's weird.
It's like, this feminist
play has become the thing
to do on a Friday night.
And it's also--
one of the schools
that we're going
to-- we're doing
a workshop at a high school
here in New York City.
And he's awesome, the dean
of the school was like,
oh no, we're going
to force them.
Everyone's just going
to be required to go.
Because that's the way to
get it going, you know.
It's just, you kind
of have to be dragged,
and then you realize
you actually like it.
And then conversation starts.
EMILY MORTIMER: And also,
speaking for myself,
I think that everybody
needs educating
about this more than
they think they do,
even the people who
think they understand it.
Like, I would think
that I would be
somebody that would be very
sort of open-minded about all
this stuff.
But I realized in talking
to Katie that there's
so much that I still don't
know and still don't understand
about sexual politics,
gender politics,
about what really goes on
between boys and girls.
And I think if
that's true for me,
it must be true for
loads of people.
KATIE CAPPIELLO: And I
think the other thing--
oh, Winnie, go ahead.
WINNIFRED BONJEAN-ALPART:
I was just going to say,
and that's also the great
thing about it being theater.
It's not a lecture about slut
shaming and sexual shaming.
It's not really
preaching to the choir
when it's a really magnificent,
entertaining piece of theater
that people should want to
see whether they're educated
about the issue or not.
And I think that that's
what we've seen a lot.
A lot of people come to see the
show because it's a great show.
It is.
And I find that
especially, a lot
of the girls that
come to see it really
identify with it wholeheartedly.
And then interestingly, when
the boys come to see it,
it's a lot more like-- they're
always a little bit more
shaken up when it's over.
I know that my friends that have
come to see it who are boys,
it's always weird between
us after they see it.
They feel like they want
to, like, hug me but they
don't want to touch me.
And I remember--
I remember I once
had one of my closest male
friends come to see it,
and he didn't know what
to say to me sort of.
And I was like, well,
what did you think?
How was it?
And he was like, I just--
I feel some type of way.
And I was like, oh, OK.
And he was like, um, I just
need to think for a while.
It was-- I don't know.
So I find that a lot of
people that come to see it
have that reaction.
KATIE CAPPIELLO:
And I think we got
some serious street cred too
because we didn't water it
down.
And that's because
of these guys.
There was no way we
weren't going to say fuck,
and there was no way we
weren't going to say pussy.
And there was no way we weren't
going to actually describe
what actually happens to a
girl when she's being violated.
We're not going to
pull punches on that
because it's enough already.
Like, people are pulling
punches too much.
So it started to spread that
we were actually going there.
FRED: And then also
this idea, then,
once they're in
there, how to get
it is, if you do it
in this very real way,
it's based on this idea that
I actually think is true.
Once you see
something, you're going
to understand more about
what's going through it,
and you're going to
have more empathy.
And you're going to
learn, not if someone's
telling you a thesis or telling
you this is the way, but by--
WINNIFRED BONJEAN-ALPART:
You feel it.
FRED: Yeah, by feeling art.
It's an advantage
to art as activism
and that once you come
here, you understand
what they're going through.
And then it just makes
more sense that way.
MEGAN MCINERNEY: And it
gives us a permission
to share stories that we
often don't hear, right?
So for the first
time, we actually
get to hear from Joey, the
survivor, a victim of rape,
when so often in these
circumstances that
are happening in real life--
whether in Steubenville,
right, or other cases around the
country that we hear about all
the time, we don't get to
hear from the survivor--
for a number of reasons, right?
And this time, theater
gives us a chance
to actually hear her voice, to
hear what actually happened,
to have to look
at her in the face
and see the reality of
how this is affecting her.
It changes you.
EMILY MORTIMER: Next question.
AUDIENCE: Thank you
guys for being here.
Thank you for making this.
My niece turns 11 this week.
Emily, you mentioned an
11-year-old son, I believe.
You mentioned 11 to
20 for your chapters
and for your group--
that's your target age.
The idea that an
11-year-old has to stand up
for herself or an
11-year-old boy
has to be educated
about things he says
or what his friends are saying--
that just-- it makes me,
it makes me sad.
It makes me mad.
Could you just talk a
little bit about how
you craft your message and
your program to kids so young?
You talked about
the girl-- was it
North Dakota-- where she
realized what had happened
to her, had been raped.
And Fred, in your
piece you talked
about guys were talking
about porn at school,
and you had to go on
Google and be like, oh, ew.
So if you could just talk
a little bit about that,
that would be helpful.
MEGAN MCINERNEY: I think
we have to acknowledge
that 11-year-olds do know
what the word slut is,
or a variation of that,
that it is affecting them
and we have to be
realistic about that.
So we actually have a
sixth grader who's 11.
She's one of our youngest
Stop Slut coalition members.
And she has a friend who
was going out with a boy.
And they were, you
know, holding hands.
And then she decided she didn't
want go out with him anymore.
And so the boy got really upset.
And he got the rest of
his peers in the class
to start calling her a thot.
And on the playground,
they started
going thot alert, thot
alert, thot alert,
every time she walked around.
And a thought, in case you don't
know, is That Ho Over There.
So it's another
derivation of slut.
And the girl was devastated.
And she's 11.
So we can't say
that 11-year-olds
aren't being impacted
by this culture, right?
It's slightly maybe different
than what high school students
are facing, but they
are experiencing
the ramifications of this.
And so we have to be willing
and courageous enough
to talk about that reality.
KATIE CAPPIELLO: And
what's so amazing is
that we hear this from middle
school students all the time,
and actually from kids in
fifth grade and fourth grade,
obviously.
And what's always
fascinating to us
is how the school handles it.
So the girl will go and be like,
they were saying thot alert,
or I'm a whole according
to James in my class.
And I don't know what to do.
And these teachers
are always like, well,
James, that is
really inappropriate
and I need you to
say you're sorry.
And never, ever, do they sit and
have a conversation about why
calling this girl a thot
or a whore or a slut
is inappropriate.
This word inappropriate gets
thrown around in middle school
like you would not believe, and
no one asks the question why?
So what we do in our program
is everything is about why.
So every time we say
something, it's about why.
So when Winnifred
was talking about
can girls reclaim the word slut?
Well, when we first started
developing this play,
we did experiment
with that possibility.
And then we kept asking
the question why.
And we started to realize, well,
no, we can't because no matter
what, it always backfires.
It just without fail backfires.
And so what we need
schools to start
doing is letting the kids
talk, actually hearing
what they're saying, not telling
them things are inappropriate.
And actually then digging deep
and unpacking it and having
a conversation about why.
Why do you think
you call her that?
Where does a sixth grade boy
learn to call this girl a thot?
Does he even know
what that means?
No.
MEGAN MCINERNEY: And it's all
the adults in their lives,
right?
So their teachers but
also their parents
and their uncles and their
aunts and religious leaders
and whoever the adults
are in their lives
taking them seriously.
It's like we were saying
before, they're the experts.
They really do understand.
Young people are smart,
and they understand
what's going on in their lives.
And so we have to be able
to give them the platform
to be able to speak
honestly and truthfully
and know that we're not
going to judge them,
we're not going to
look down on them,
but we're going to
actually listen and then
help give them the tools
that they need to create
the change that they want.
KATIE CAPPIELLO:
Ask a sixth grader
or a fifth grader that you
know, or a fourth grader,
or maybe even a third
grader, if they've ever
heard the word slut
or whore or ho,
and they will tell you, yes.
Except no one's
ever asking them.
No one's asking kids
that age, right?
So that's a part of the problem.
And when you get to
the high school level,
high schools don't want to
talk about slut shaming.
They don't want to talk
about rape culture.
They'll talk about bullying,
but they won't talk about this
because this involves sex.
And no one wants to
think that kids this age
are engaging in sex,
because God forbid, right.
EMILY MORTIMER: Next question.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
That was really
fantastic, impressive.
And I'm really excited
about these stories
of change in places that you've
been going and doing this play.
It's great to hear.
I don't suspect you have an
Australian tour coming up
any time soon?
KATIE CAPPIELLO: We'd love it.
MEGAN MCINERNEY: Yeah.
MEGAN MCINERNEY:
Make that happen.
KATIE CAPPIELLO: Make
some connections.
AUDIENCE: So similar
to the last question,
I have a 10-year-old sister.
And I'm terrified of
her going to high school
in a couple of years
and having to deal
with the immense
social pressures
from girls, from boys, from
adults, from music videos,
from the way we market
toys to children.
It's disgusting.
And so I'm wondering,
do you guys
have recommendations on how to
talk to young girls about this
and to make sure
that they understand
all the support they have?
EMILY MORTIMER: I was going
to ask Odley that question,
because I didn't get to ask
my question earlier to her.
In fact, I was going
to say the same thing.
What would you tell
your 10-year-old self
about to enter into big school?
How would you prepare her?
ODLEY: First thing
I would tell myself
is, it's not fun to have
champagne poured in your face.
No, the first thing I
would have really, really
took my time to repeat
to myself is be yourself.
You don't have to-- often
girls do most things
because other girls are doing it
or they want a guy's attention.
And the big thing is,
you have to be yourself,
whether you like dancing or
twerking around, then go ahead
and do it.
But don't do it to get
somebody's attention, you know.
Just be yourself
100%, and that's
what we need to remember
most of the time.
DARCI SIEGEL: I
mean, just growing up
as a teen in this
generation with all
of these influences of media
that have been surrounding
us-- there's a really huge
dichotomy between being
a sexual person and being
a smart person, right.
So you can either be a
really empowered person
who loves your body, or
you can be a smart person.
And you can't-- they've made
it so that you can't be both.
And by "they," I mean society
because you can either
be really sexual-- you can
embrace your sexuality,
but if you embrace it,
then you can be a slut
or you can be somewhat
more conservative.
But if you're more conservative
then you're a prude.
And there are just so many
ways where you can be one
but then you can't be the other.
And what I would
tell younger me,
and what I'm still even
telling myself now, is that I
can embrace both, you know.
So you can tell your
11-year-old sister
that it's OK to feel
good about yourself
and to feel good
about your body,
and you can also be smart.
So just embrace it and don't
let other people tell you
that what you're doing is wrong.
WINNIFRED BONJEAN-ALPART: May I
quickly say also about the word
"slut," in particular.
I think for me, the first time
I remember someone calling me
a slut, I was probably 10 or 11.
And at the time there was no
sexual connotation, really.
I mean, I was really
disassociated,
because honestly now for me,
there isn't really that either.
It has always been a word that
is used to dehumanize, degrade,
and demean someone, make
someone feel like trash.
And that is its
effect, regardless
of your sexual history.
I mean, when I was 10, I
had never kissed a boy,
but the word felt really bad.
So I think that's how you
address it with young people.
They know that the
word feels bad,
and that's pretty much
all there is to it.
The reason why it
feels bad is because it
makes you feel worthless.
And honestly, there is
no other word like that.
The word bitch, the word
cunt-- those words are nothing
like the word slut,
because to me, it's
the only word that actually
makes you feel like trash
and then therefore it
becomes really problematic
because you can do
anything you want
to trash without
any consequences.
So it's all like--
FRED: Yeah, to be called,
even on the other side,
like "pussy" or "fag," those
don't mean what they mean.
We're taking this kind of
jealousy and this anger
that we have and we're putting
it into something that's
already so taboo that
we don't know what
it is because no one's talking
about it-- meaning that,
then, oh, so then put this
there and then-- yeah.
KATIE CAPPIELLO: And I think
with your sister, so much of it
is just is modeling too.
I think people don't even
realize how often they say this
word or how often they'll just
be like, ah, she's-- like,
why is she even
acting like that?
Like, she's such trash,
or she's such a whore.
We just do it so flippantly.
And I actually had this really
cool chat with Fred's mom.
And she was just like,
oh shit, and making
me realize all the things
I said over the years
that were really degrading.
And I'm doing it
in front of my kid
who's modeling his
behavior off mine.
And so much of what we see
with kids slut shaming one
another we see parents doing.
Not kidding.
We see parents doing
it to other girls.
This play is based off
a lot of real events.
And in a particular
event in this play,
a mom that we are
very close with,
who prides herself on being a
feminist, who we would agree
is a really great person, came
up to me and was like, I mean,
do you believe this girl?
I mean, come on,
she's such a slut.
She's such a liar.
And you're sitting there.
And you're just like,
is she even thinking?
And I know she said
that to her daughter.
I know her daughter
told her friends.
I know they're saying that
at the PTA meeting, for real.
And so it's what we're
modeling, you know.
And it's also just,
bring up the word.
Have you ever heard
this word before?
these things before?
And let her know that
you're willing to have
an open dialogue.
Most kids don't
feel like anyone's
willing to talk
about it with them.
And if they do, it means
they're bad, especially girls.
They always feel bad.
Like, they're bad and dirty.
EMILY MORTIMER: Next question.
AUDIENCE: So on the one hand,
media like pornography or music
videos like "Big Pimpin'," maybe
they have some negative side
effects when people are
watching too many of them.
On the other hand, people
have a right to free speech.
So how do we maybe stop
people from consuming
as much media that is degrading
to women or other people?
What's the solution to
that balance of free speech
and negative side effects.
FRED: So I wrote
that a year ago,
and then they told
me to read it.
And I was also nervous
because I don't
want to tell people
what not to make,
and there should be videos
of people having sex.
Like, that should be
something that someone
can access and look at.
I think it's not
that we're telling
"Big Pimpin'" not to be made.
We're not doing that, but we're
exercising our free speech
to say, personally, to me,
this is what I think of that.
So like, whatever
music video is made,
we're not telling the writer--
they should, you know,
write whatever they want and
exercise that free speech as
much as they want.
It's just, by doing that,
we have the same free speech
to say that affected
this thing in a way
that I don't like how it looked.
And then maybe if they heard
that and maybe if we talked,
they could still
make it, but they
have a different
understanding of it.
So in no way is it
saying stop doing this.
It's just saying, your
very personal thing, this
is how it affects me.
EMILY MORTIMER: Yeah,
or like the guys
at the high school refusing
to dance to "Blurred Lines."
They're not saying that
shouldn't be published
as a record, but we
don't like the feeling
of-- but that was a really
interesting one, I thought,
that "Blurred Lines"
video and the song
because there was something
very kind of viscerally
weirdly appealing about
it, even as a woman.
It was like, this
guy was sort of being
so overt in a way that you
couldn't tell whether it
was ironic or what it was.
But there was something kind
of-- you were drawn to it.
And I feel that the confusion
around things like that
is something that you guys-- and
then when you think about it,
you think, this
is just horrible.
I hate this song.
I hate this video.
But there's something
very compelling about it
at the same time.
And no wonder it was
a huge hit because it
appeals to some part
of us that still
hasn't been reconciled at all.
And we're still very
un-reconstructed as a culture,
even though we think we are.
So I think that's an
excellent question.
And there, we have an example
of people actually thinking
about this song and
deciding to use their right
to not dance to it.
MEGAN MCINERNEY: Exactly.
And I think that's
the whole point.
If we can have a space where
we can actually stop for second
and not just have
everything bombard us
and be naive or keeping our eyes
open to how it's affecting us--
that's part of the problem,
is that it's just all
coming at us so
quickly, so quickly,
especially with social media and
easy access to things like porn
right now.
You're not even aware of
how it's affecting you.
And so our position
is oftentimes,
OK, let's just stop for a second
and have a conversation so
that we can be more aware and
make our own personal decision
if we want to continue
to consume this or not.
WINNIFRED BONJEAN-ALPART: Yeah.
And I think I also,
like, with free speech
comes responsibility.
And you can technically say
whatever you want to say,
but with some knowledge of
how it's affecting others
is really important.
And I think a lot
of it, especially
with porn, obviously it comes
down to supply and demand.
So it's less about changing an
artist's perspective or goal
in producing his porn, but
more about what we as a society
value and how we
want to treat people.
I mean, to me, like, the porn
industry is really specific.
But I mean, it's the same
thing with music videos.
I mean, it's a societal issue.
So once we sort of change
the energy of our culture,
then naturally art changes.
EMILY MORTIMER: Thank you.
Last two questions.
AUDIENCE: So thank you
guys for coming today.
I know you guys said
that you brought
the play to a bunch of
different parts of the country.
And some parts of the
country are probably
a lot more conservative about
talking about sex and sex
education, maybe for whatever
reasons, religious reasons.
They may not go into it as in
depth at some other schools
in the country.
So did you guys
have an opportunity
to visit these more
conservative areas?
And if so, how were
their reactions?
And were they different
depending on where you visited
throughout the country?
DARCI SIEGEL: Well,
when we went to Fargo,
North Dakota-- I mean,
that's the Midwest.
So it's pretty conservative.
And before the show,
we were talking
to some of the teens that were
waiting to go see the show.
And we were talking about
their sex ed classes.
And in the city-- I go to a
New York City public school,
and so we do have health ed.
And we have started to talk
about consent and about how
to treat your interaction
with the opposite sex,
and stuff like that.
And when I went to Fargo, I was
talking to one of the girls.
And I was talking to her,
and I was asking her, I said,
what's your sex ed class like?
And she goes, well,
actually, it's
really funny that you asked
me that, because a couple
weeks ago in sex ed we
played a game called
who slept in your bed?
And what they did is they put
a white sheet on the floor.
And then everyone
sat around the sheet,
and they had little pictures
of different characters.
And there would be, like, Slutty
Amanda or like Herpes Harry,
and all of these
different things
that were geared towards
telling these students,
don't have sex because these
are all of the things that's
going to happen to you, right.
You can be called a slut,
or you can get an STD.
And the way that
it was constructed
is just don't have sex because
all these bad things are
going to happen to you.
And what they don't do is
they don't prepare students
with the conversation, with
the resources for those
who do want to have sex.
And so just when we
went and we started
having an open
conversation with them,
they were so eager to have these
conversations about sexuality
and about slut
shaming and about sex.
And so I just
think it was great.
ELIZA PRICE: Yeah, I agree.
And we have a line
earlier in the play
that's talking about how
this woman's a Republican.
And before we went
to Fargo, we were
considering changing it
to like, oh, well, she's
so conservative.
And then we didn't.
And I thought that was so cool
because we didn't-- OK, sorry.
Because if we changed
it to conservative,
we'd be picking what
their reactions were going
to be before we'd met
them and before we'd seen
their response to the play.
And so I remember, we were all
a little bit nervous before.
Were they going to like it?
Were they going to laugh?
Were they going to be emotional?
And it was so powerful.
That was the most powerful place
I had been a part of the play
because they reacted just
like they reacted in New York
and LA-- even more
so because they don't
have the same opportunities
to witness theater
like we do or you guys do,
or to talk about it openly.
And so it didn't really matter
that we had Republican in there
or that we were
talking about sex.
Because everybody goes
through the same things,
and it was just so beautiful
to give them that opportunity.
WINNIFRED BONJEAN-ALPART:
I think we
as New Yorkers also
underestimate people
all over the rest of the world.
Like, they're
actually not that bad.
I remember going there and being
like, oh my god, North Dakota--
they're pilgrims.
I don't know what's
going to happen.
And I got there.
And I mean, my part in
particular is pretty racy.
And it was straight
faces, enthusiasm.
People loved it.
It was the same exact way as
it was here, as it was in LA.
KATIE CAPPIELLO: We were
warned too, before we went.
They were like,
listen, just prepare.
There's going to be picketing.
They are going to hate you.
This is just
feminist propaganda.
And we're like, oh my god, this
is going to be unbelievable.
We were a little excited for it,
to be really honest with you.
We were like, we're pumped.
We were prepping on the plane.
We were like, we're going
to say this in response.
But I'm telling you, there
was a line around the block.
This show sold out.
And we're not talking just
teenagers-- parents, educators.
The first high school,
the very first high school
that welcomed us
into their halls
to do a workshop about
rape and slut shaming
was a little high school
in Moorhead, Minnesota,
you know what I mean?
And it's Lutheran as it gets.
So they want to
talk about it too.
They just need access.
We need to get in there.
So we're working on it.
So we're going to Boston.
So we're excited about that.
I mean, it's pretty East Coast,
pretty liberal and pretty--
I mean, it'll be great.
We're going to go to DC.
We're going to San Francisco.
And we're really,
really working hard
for some Bible Belt situation.
If you have any ideas,
please let us know.
EMILY MORTIMER: Last question.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks again for coming.
I know you mentioned-- so you
focus on 11 to 20-year-olds
for the conversations.
I want to know, how can we have
those types of conversations
for 20-plus, and how
can we kind of bridge
that gap to help that education
be for the older crowd too?
EMILY MORTIMER:
Very good question.
MEGAN MCINERNEY: Just do
it is what I would say.
I mean, it doesn't have
to be anything formal.
I mean, we have
laid out in the book
entire activist guide at the
end that Katie and I wrote
that helps either with
questions to start off with
to help guide the conversation,
or different plans of action
that other people have
done around the country.
But really, it doesn't
take much to just
be able to sit down with a group
of friends over a cup of coffee
and be like, all right,
let's talk about this.
It's really effective.
We've had so many conversations
with our adult friends.
And it's just about sitting
around and being brave enough
to start that dialogue
and to be honest about how
it's affecting you.
KATIE CAPPIELLO: I
think Google needs
to start a Stop Slut chapter.
MEGAN MCINERNEY: Yeah.
KATIE CAPPIELLO: Are
you guys down for it?
And there's one thing
that we find works
that we have found works.
It doesn't matter the age group.
It's a writing exercise.
And maybe that sounds a little
cheesy and a little college
writing workshop.
But we have a writing prompt
online that you can easily
access and download.
And we find, if you give someone
a second, if you give them
seven minutes, all it takes
is seven minutes to sit there
and actually think, oh, how
is this touching my life,
you're going to start to
find all these things are
going to come up.
And it's not just things from
seventh grade or 10th grade.
It's things from
your subway ride.
You know what I mean?
It's things from that
night at that get together
two weeks ago, you know?
I was at a party very recently
with a group of friends.
And I'm sitting across this
gentleman who's 35-years-old
making rape jokes
the whole night,
and no one's saying anything.
No one's saying anything.
And I'm sitting there.
And I'm like-- and the women
are all making eye contact,
and no one is saying anything.
And it's just-- it's everywhere.
And so I think if you give
yourself that seven minutes
to just acknowledge how
it's touching your life,
that's the first step.
And so maybe there's
some sort of little club
that you guys can start and
do some writing and some
reflecting.
ODLEY: Just to add on.
I guess just, what's really
big is to remind ourselves,
after 20, it doesn't
mean that life is over.
And you stop partying and you
just have to find a husband
and you get married.
And you won't be called a slut
anymore because you're old
and all that stuff.
Stuff like this doesn't
only happen to teenagers.
It happens to 35-year-olds
with three kids at home.
They're still being sexually
assaulted in the streets
or at work.
And sad to say, older
women are being raped too.
And we shouldn't have
to be afraid to open
this conversation and actually
speak up and tell our story.
And you're not too old
to tell your story if it
happened a year ago, you know?
And it's like, life and slut
shaming doesn't end at an age.
It goes on, and it's wrong.
And I guess when we
open a conversation,
we can all say, OK, it's wrong.
It doesn't happen
to only teenagers
because they're fragile
and small all that stuff.
It happens to all of us.
And it shouldn't be hard to have
the conversation because you're
older and you have better
things to worry about, you know?
EMILY MORTIMER: Well, I
am so grateful to have
been part of this conversation.
I can't tell you.
I feel educated.
The beginning of an education
is starting for me, just
from having been
around these guys
and being exposed to their
honesty and their willingness
to talk and be open about these
incredibly important issues.
And so I'd love to thank you
all so much for coming and Katie
and Meg for starting
this incredible thing
and for keeping it going.
And thank you so much to
Google for hosting us.
It's an amazing
platform for these guys
to come and tell their story.
And thank you for having us.
And thank you, Feminist Press,
for publishing the book.
And you guys can pick up the
book-- here, I think, right?
Get the book.
The book is awesome.
I can't stop reading it.
Every subway ride I'm
on, I'm like this.
It's really good.
And my 11-year-old
kid keeps saying,
Mom, it's so embarrassing,
reading that book.
Will you please put it away?
And I'm like, no.
You should come to
this talk with me.
KATIE CAPPIELLO:
Yeah, that's right.
EMILY MORTIMER:
No, I'm not coming.
DARCI SIEGEL: That's so cute.
EMILY MORTIMER: Anyway, so
thank you so much for having us
and for staying long after
you should be home probably.
Thank you.
KATIE CAPPIELLO: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]